hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Miami shark now this is
one of my favorite games of all time on
Newgrounds and you'll see why real quick
it's not a very long game but you'll get
what I mean by why it's awesome
oh you literally just play a shark oh
wait hang up an hand huh
gotcha oh no no freak uh-huh no hang on
wait
I forgot the controls you just grab on
the [ __ ] and you drag it down to our
level
sheriff more like share with the ocean
is cuz I'm gonna eat you and so you're
okay so you play as a shark and you need
you're having a good I think you're
trying to get to your migratory area so
you can breed but before you do that you
need to like destroy everything in your
path Oh private jet more like my Vinci
so like this is the entirety of the game
right so it's cool game because I'm a
badass shark I'm on a dragon for the US
army more like my arm my I don't know
I'm to try and make it up as I go along
here huh oh come on nope nope nope
come on give me give yes airliner more
like ocean liner
hey I did it I killed everyone on that
plane now it's good right
dolphins this boats man's Yasmin's
another airliner oh man oh it's the
Space Shuttle holy [ __ ]
let make out a breath why am I out of
breath playing a video game
hmm I should probably go outside
sometime but then again sharks are
outside and you can't be safe in the
Sharks about till you definitely don't
want to go outside you want sense and
play video games all day every day
blam hook excuse me sir do you know its
way to the ocean
aye sir well why is no one talking to me
I'm flapping my mouth what sir
oh no no no dip give give give give give
Jeff Jeff you're us you're mine oh it's
one of the planes it flies other plane
parts time to die apparently of the blue
via Beluga more like belugas belonging
the Ducks also I'm so sorry ducks well
not really constructs are dicks yeah
only a few miles left I don't know what
that means
yeah I just gotta destroy as much as
possible oh ah sr22 blackbird oh that
was mine it was gonna be mine oh I
failed
I got try again hey sheriff you want
there's a crime happening in the ocean
you gonna check this out oh no he done
then a lien destroying something in the
background over there oh is that a shark
destroying something in the foreground
over here probably
oh hey hey thank you oh by the way
that's cool thing happening in the ocean
oh my god I know right it's so cool oh
you grew up
Oh heart flutter hair
thank you coming in long I'm not gonna
miss you this time
Oh ducks I forgot about the Ducks I
don't have a problem don't look at me
like that
I'm a perfectly functioning shark in the
ocean in fact I'm fantastic
breath mine now sr22 blackbird more like
that's our doing to my bird oh it's a b2
but that wasn't a b2 I thought though I
don't know what a b2 is oh oh oh
more ah mine mine mine mine
Oh b-52 is that what this is it's an
abbey v Oh
oh you robbed me oh you robbed me oh I
had that damn it damn it
mmm
anyway you can play this game for
yourself down through the link of the
description below there's actually other
versions of this game like in Sydney in
New York so if you want to see me play
those and you probably do because I'm so
awesome at being a shark and killing
everybody but if you want to see those
let me know in the comments below thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
how's the thread shot the hatch is mine
it doesn't matter it's for the Chris on
his mind with all we can't afford very
expensive hat Oh
oh we're going how look okay